welcome to the historic rang you're a
town hall on the corner of high and king
streets originally opened in 1926 the
refurbished and restored Town Hall
reopened on the 7th of March 2015 the
improved facilities include a larger
entrance with disabled access to the
right of the entrance hall are two 23
seats state-of-the-art cinemas to the
left is the entrance to the town hall
auditorium which sits 360 people the
auditorium which is available for hire
as an ideal venue for musical events
shows and concerts drama productions
prize-giving sword ceremonies conference
presentations at events requiring a
stage comfortable seating and excellent
acoustics tickets to cinemas and
auditorium performances and refreshments
can be purchased from the ground floor
foyer a function room on the first floor
which has both a full bar and catering
service can be hired for pre and post
auditorium events or hired separately
for meetings and private functions the
function room has a capacity of 140
standing guests or 90 seated and is
accessed by a lift and stairs from the
entrance hall also accessed from the
entrance hall is the new 150 seat
theatre with retractable seating and
stage an extremely versatile space the
theater can be hired for drama dance and
musical performances seminars and
meetings all areas including the stage
are wheelchair accessible for studio
meeting rooms are also on the first
floor soundproofed air-conditioned and
comfortably sitting 12 these rooms can
be hired individually or together for
meetings or music rehearsals an adjacent
green room provides an informal relaxing
space with kitchen facilities including
a fridge and microwave oven the rang
you're a town hall restored refurbished
and ready to serve the waimakariri
community for the next 90 years